i
[Música]
bienvenidos al debate de france 24 soy
santiago lópez gonzález el mundo está
frente a sus últimas horas para poner en
marcha las estrategias contundentes
contra el calentamiento global la cumbre
de la cob 26 que tiene lugar en la
ciudad de glasgow en escocia se juega
todo su prestigio y credibilidad con un
desfile de mandatarios con unos
discursos llenos de promesas y de planes
pero las organizaciones internacionales
y también la sociedad civil los
activistas y otros sectores reclaman a
viva voz acciones verdaderas
contundentes es ahora o nunca para
revertir el daño ambiental que hemos
ocasionado a nuestro planeta en el
siguiente informe elaborado por la
redacción de france 24 les presentamos
algunas de las propuestas que han hecho
los asistentes a este evento entre ellas
sobresale ese compromiso del sector
financiero para financiar con diferentes
planes en diferentes países del mundo
proyectos que beneficien al medio
ambiente veamos
limitar el aumento de la temperatura del
planeta a 15 grados celsius sobre los
niveles preindustriales el objetivo
clave para evitar una mayor catástrofe
climática como hacerlo reduciendo los
gases de efecto invernadero sobre todo a
través de la merma del consumo de carbón
petróleo y gas tres motores de la
economía internacional su costo unos 100
billones de dólares según el enviado
para el clima de naciones unidas y que
se haría haciendo una transición hacia
inversiones amigables con el medio
ambiente many green new world son muchas
energías renovables son ahora más
baratas que los combustibles fósiles y
tienen menos costos de operación a largo
plazo otras tecnologías verdes tienen
curvas de costo que han seguido bajando
de quini point de muchas maneras
simplemente es más efectivo
transformarse hacia lo verde
ya un conglomerado de inversores bancos
y aseguradoras que representan un 40 por
ciento del capital mundial afirmaron
tener a su disposición 130 billones de
dólares para combatir el cambio
climático esto en el sector privado
cuando hablamos de los actores estatales
el llamado llega desde los países en
vías de desarrollo que denuncian el
incumplimiento por parte de las
economías avanzadas del objetivo de
entregarles anualmente 100 mil millones
de dólares para 2020 y así contribuir en
la lucha contra el cambio climático
si hay un compromiso político si hay una
voluntad hay un camino hemos
identificado todos los problemas todo el
mundo conoce los problemas pero hay una
falta de compromiso político con el
objetivo para 2020 sin cumplirse el
presidente de la cob 26 estima que entre
2021 y 2025 el total de la ayuda para
los países en vías de desarrollo llegue
a los 500 mil millones de dólares
para analizar este tema hemos invitado a
gustavo máñez él es coordinador de
cambio climático para américa latina y
el caribe del programa de la onu para el
medio ambiente se encuentra en ciudad de
panamá panamá también está con nosotros
el doctor aníbal púlsar él es director
del instituto de ecología y
biodiversidad de la universidad de
concepción en chile él se encuentra
precisamente allí en el sur de chile en
la ciudad de concepción y aquí en el
estudio de france 24 me acompaña
catalina góngora especialista en
políticas públicas de the nature
conservancy
ustedes nuestros televidentes también
pueden participar en este debate con
todos sus comentarios y sus preguntas a
través de las redes sociales estamos en
facebook en instagram y en twitter si
ganas como france24 de un bajo ese
arroba sant y luego que es mi cuenta
personal nuestra etiqueta es numeral el
debate efe 24 esperamos todos sus
comentarios y sus preguntas comienzo con
catalina aquí en el estudio de france 24
bienvenida gracias por acompañarnos aquí
en el debate y cuáles son sus
impresiones catalina destacó 26 de estos
días que ha transcurrido esta cumbre
allí en glasgow
buenas noches santiago gracias
bueno pues en general
hay muchos debates sobre la mesa
yo diría que esta semana se ha
concentrado digamos estos días que
llevan las negociaciones han concentrado
en abordar la ambición que se requiere
para que los países
aumenten sus metas y los porcentajes de
reducción de gases de carbono a través
de sus heces que es como el mecanismo
que establecido el acuerdo de parís
para que los países digamos renueven
cada cinco años estas metas y se logren
los objetivos del convenio
entonces se ha concentrado mucho en
compromisos y acuerdos políticos y
generar este ambiente de voluntad
política de los jefes de estados que va
a facilitar que los negociadores que
tienen que abordar los temas críticos
del acuerdo y que se puedan llevar a
cabo los temas de los mercados de
carbono que es toda la negociación del
artículo 6
en las negociaciones sobre el tema de
transferencia cada cuánto los países
tienen que reportar la información de
qué manera lo hacen o por ejemplo los
compromisos en adaptación que claramente
se avanzado más en mitigación que en
adaptación a todos estos temas que hay
que abordar que le dé luces a los
negociadores para que las tensiones que
normalmente se dan se puedan llevar a
cabo entonces pues yo creo que llegamos
hasta se han plasmado estas voluntades
políticas hay muchos acuerdos tanto
sectoriales y hoy fue el día de la
energía como como puntuales en
movilización de recursos y que el tema
la implementación de la gran deuda
pendiente que lo que está esperando la
sociedad en pocas palabras gustado en la
ciudad de panamá a sus impresiones sobre
los avances que ha habido allí en la cop
26 y si hay alguno de los acuerdos que
usted quiera destacar
bueno sí que se ha hablado mucho estos
días de finanzas como en todos estos
grandes bancos y entidades financieras
aseguradoras que se han comprometido a
redireccionar sus recursos a inversiones
pues alineadas con el clima no tanto en
mitigación como una adaptación el tema
del metano no es el gran gasto olvidado
pero que tiene un potencial de
calentamiento
hasta 85 veces superior al co2 y donde
también ha habido un compromiso más de
100 gobiernos en el tema de los bosques
también como estábamos haciendo antes
estos son compromisos que no son
vinculantes
lo verdaderamente vinculantes son estas
n veces estos compromisos que se someten
cada cinco años al acuerdo de parís a
naciones unidas y que lo que hacen es
marcar pues ese esa vinculación de lo
que va a hacer el país concretamente
para cumplir con ese objetivo de 1.5
grados lo que nos dijo la agencia
internacional de la energía
unas pocas semanas fue que no podemos
sacar más petróleo ni gas ni carbón de
la tierra ni quemarlo obviamente si
queremos cumplir con el objetivo del 15
grados y para eso todavía nos queda
muchísima distancia si otro informe que
publicamos hace unos días calculamos que
con esa serie de heces a nivel global
estaríamos en un calentamiento de 27
grados muy lejos del 1,5 grados que nos
mantiene en una temperatura
aún con impactos pero gestionando
el doctor richard le hago la misma
pregunta para terminar esta primera
ronda para abrir el debate y abrir la
conversación que puede destacar usted de
lo que llevamos destacó 26 que se puede
es de destacar y que se puede recoger de
estos acuerdos cuáles son sus
impresiones
hola gracias bastante
muchas gracias por invitarme a este
programa y lo primero yo creo que es
destacar que realmente el tema del
cambio climático ya no es algo que es de
una clase elite política sino que
académica sino que claramente ahora está
a cargo de muchos líderes mundiales y en
lo más importante incluso que está
llegando a la casa de todas las personas
y yo creo que con eso también se ha
ganado un punto de visible de
visibilización del tema que hasta hace
años atrás parecía increíble no ahora
eso es por la gravedad del tema es ahora
o nunca y así se ha dicho en varias
oportunidades por lo tanto yo no soy tan
optimista respecto a lo que a los
acuerdos que se están logrando esta vez
porque también ha habido críticas
profundas a que esto más bien parece que
no es cierto una suerte de lavado de
imagen de ciertos países entonces hay
que tener claridad de que realmente si
queremos hacer cambio hay que ir fuerte
al fondo del asunto y ese es ese cambio
van va más allá digamos no es solamente
cuánto carbono yo produzco sino todo el
modelo
y de producción y eso realmente cuesta
mucho cambiarlo entonces también hay que
hay que ir viendo cómo esto va
ocurriendo
yo quiero destacar y quizás no hablamos
después el tema de la deforestación que
hay una meta bien interesante sobre el
2030 es uno de los de los temas que
tenemos en la agenda para hablar ahorita
más adelante doctor púlsar continuó con
usted allí en concepción en el sur de
chile
quisiera preguntarle entonces cuál
debería ser ese gran cambio que debería
de dar el mundo entero para mejorar los
indicadores que tenemos en este momento
deberíamos apostarle por un modelo
económico verde eso sí se podrá lograr
en un tiempo determinado
tal vez mediano plazo
bueno probablemente no soy la persona
para poder responder eso pero si lo que
creo es que tiene que haber un cambio en
nuestra forma de consumo y en nuestro en
nuestra manera relacionarnos con la
naturaleza eso es lo que estamos
proponiendo por ejemplo a través de ypfb
es que esta plataforma
intergubernamental de biodiversidad y
cambio climático ahí estamos proponiendo
que es importante que haya
un cambio en la relación que tenemos con
la naturaleza eso yo creo que es hay que
buscar este este ángulo que es distinto
no solamente de donde sacamos la energía
sino cómo nos relacionamos con la
naturaleza qué es lo que tenemos que
solucionar si gustado en la ciudad de
panamá para hacer esta ronda la inversa
y terminar con con catalina aquí en el
estudio gustado usted hablaba de estos
acuerdos como unos acuerdos que no son
vinculantes porque a estas alturas
cuando ya estamos en un momento límite
prácticamente vamos caminando por el
filo del precipicio antes de llegar a
una una verdadera catástrofe ambiental
porque no son vinculantes este tipo de
acuerdos porque no ponen un poco más de
presión sobre las autoridades sobre la
sociedad para hacer un poco más
conscientes de la de actuar rápido
definitivamente hay que poner presión
sobre los tomadores de decisiones porque
como dijo el secretario general hace
unos días
estamos tratando al planeta como si
fuera un baño no un váter
y el problema no es
intrínsecamente el planeta en sí el
problema va a ser que los seres humanos
que dependemos de la naturaleza desde el
aire que respiramos hasta el agua que
bebemos pues se nos va a hacer la vida
imposible y de ahí pues todas estas
teorías que llegan de la colapso logía
que cada vez parecen estás más cercanas
de lo que puede pasar si no
paramos esta adicción que tenemos como
especie a los combustibles fósiles sin
embargo cómo hacerlo está bastante claro
porque las soluciones tecnológicas están
ahí no se tienen que inventar
chile recientemente anunciado que va a
prohibir el motor de combustión interna
en el año 2035
el sector transporte es el que más está
creciendo en emisiones no solamente en
américa latina y el caribe sino a nivel
mundial entonces lo mismo se puede hacer
con sectores como las energías
renovables dejar de generar electricidad
con petróleo con carbón y hacerlo con el
sol hacerlo con el viento con la
geotermia las soluciones tecnologías
están ahí lo que pasa es que hay
intereses comerciales intereses
políticos muy ligados estes intereses
comerciales pues que intentan
rentabilizar hasta el máximo
porque saben que se les está acabando el
tiempo porque saben que estas
tecnologías pues no son tan eficientes y
no traen tanto rendimiento económico
pero quieren apurar al máximo de ahí esa
poca ambición que estamos viendo en la
senda de cesc y de ahí la necesidad de
hacer presión cada vez más fuerte pues
con aquellos gobiernos que no están
siendo lo suficientemente ambiciosos y
es más
tenemos varios ejemplos de ellos no son
países pequeños sino que son los grandes
y los mayores contribuyentes al cambio
climático eso me lleva a la pregunta que
le quería hacer a catalina aquí en el
estudio de france 24 porque cuesta tanto
poner en marcha las políticas públicas
para llevar a cabo este tipo de de
compromisos a nivel internacional porque
los gobiernos en américa latina'
hablemos sólo de nuestra región por el
momento cuesta tanto poner en marcha
este tipo de compromisos
bueno santiago esto se relaciona con el
modelo de desarrollo y como decía
gustavo creo en la forma que consumimos
y producimos entonces es cambiar todo el
digamos una transformación sistémica
y uno de los temas más importantes
precisamente en la cope es el
financiamiento y lo que mencionaba
gustavo es hay estos compromisos de
movilizar recursos pero realmente lo que
hay que pensar es no solamente movilizar
recursos sino de dónde vienen esos
recursos y hay que empezar a abordar a
la eliminación de
financiamiento negativo que tiene
impacto en el clima y ahí es donde
realmente se logra digamos los cambios
transformacional es empezar a reducir la
manera como se hace se se impacta
climáticamente hay una serie de
soluciones que están en marcha y hay un
la discusión sobre los flujos de
recursos
y ya digamos en estas discusiones esta
primera semana es muy de compromisos
políticos y la semana que le queda la
copa es realmente ver las reglas y los
procedimientos
muestras se logran consensos que pueden
ser sostenibles en el tiempo y claro eso
es paso a paso de pronto digamos está
esta cop no logra como tal un cambio
total del 'business as usual' pues como
se llama un poco la forma como
funcionamos ahora y que tenemos que
impactar pero ahí hay unos mecanismos
que se llaman las soluciones basadas en
la naturaleza y es
como podemos desde la naturaleza empezar
a generar este cambio sistémico
y apuntándola a todos los beneficios a
adaptación y mitigación también a
biodiversidad como mencionaba gustavo
que es donde logramos como ese win win
ese se gana gana de todo el sistema
entonces creo que ahí es donde está como
como el punto de quiebre a dónde se
podría apuntar los recursos de dónde
están los préstamos de la banca
multilateral hacia dónde van y claro
cómo se pueden transformar
los grandes nichos
productores de carbón ha
gustado quiero preguntarle por dos
países o dos representantes de dos
estados muy particulares y uno es yo va
a tener presidente de eeuu que marca
un regreso de eeuu en esta escena
medioambiental a nivel mundial y también
boris johnson el primer ministro
británico que está allí para tratar de
mostrar el liderazgo del reino unido- a
nivel medioambiental ahora que se ha
retirado de la unión europea que el
reino unido está por su cuenta y quiere
pues abanderarse un poco con su país en
estos en estos temas como ven ustedes el
regreso de eeuu sabemos lo importante
que es esta economía a nivel mundial
pero también el peso medioambiental que
genera para todo el planeta la economía
de eeuu y este abanderamiento que está
tomando el reino unido- como lo ven
ustedes a nivel internacional
bueno pues a nivel de lo que significa
tener a eeuu otra vez en la mesa es
genial es genial porque le dan un
impulso al diálogo político y de alguna
manera de ejercer presión en otros
países que se hubieran mantenido pues en
una posición digamos más conservadora
y en américa latina pues por ejemplo lo
hemos visto con ciertos cambios de
discurso no sé si acciones concretas
pero sí de discurso por ejemplo de la
administración brasileña pero también de
la administración mexicana en cuanto a
cambio climático
aparte de que bueno pues históricamente
son el mayor contribuyente al cambio
climático y todo el movimiento de su
economía
y de las inversiones que pueden hacer si
van en la buena dirección pues
verdaderamente pueden ser
transformadoras pues a nuestra región
específicamente nos beneficia mucho una
buena dirección el rol que está tomando
el reino unido- bueno pues como
presidencia de la cob tienen en sus
espaldas un gran peso de asegurarse de
que sea un éxito de que se concluyan a
aquellos aspectos que quedan por cerrar
en la cob sobre todo el tema que ha sido
mencionado antes de la transparencia las
reglas cómo vamos a reportar que estamos
avanzando con esos compromisos la sede
de cesc y sobre todo el artículo 6 los
mercados de carbono no verdaderamente
cerrar ya esta discusión para que estos
mercados de carbono funcionen de una
manera efectiva y no se aire caliente y
doble contabilidad etcétera etcétera
entonces pues no es muy importante y
obviamente que tiene el reino unido- de
fuerte que es un sector financiero
nasheet y muy fuerte que también está
haciendo compromisos por lo menos de
palabra
fuertes en este sentido esperemos que
gracias a ese impulso de la presidencia
británica pues esto vaya a pasar y esas
inversiones
del sector financiero que es la sangre
de la economía que va a parar a los
órganos que son las empresas etcétera
pues que esa sangre vaya a los órganos
correctos y que no vaya pues a generar
más carbón
justamente el doctor pulsar el primer
ministro británico boris johnson ha sido
uno de los abanderados ha llevado a cabo
y ha puesto sobre la mesa
en esta cumbre él fue el que hizo el
anuncio de un gran acuerdo internacional
contra la deforestación un tema que
usted ya estaba mencionando
anteriormente esto es una alianza de
gobiernos inversores empresas
organizaciones medioambientales para
detener la pérdida de los bosques en el
mundo y también la degradación de la
tierra para el 2030 estamos a tiempo
para lograrlo de aquí al 2030 muchos
dicen que simplemente darles 10 años más
para seguir
arrasando un poco más los bosques y al
final de la década empezar a ponerse
juiciosos
sí exactamente esa fue la primera
crítica no porque no empezar hoy día si
los mecanismos están los países ya
tienen cierta estructura de manejo de
sus bosques tienen inventarios
forestales entonces es relativamente
sencillo poder empezar con meta en 2021
lo cierto pero bueno obviamente entiendo
todo esto tiene que ver con las
negociaciones internacionales la
pregunta es cuán duro va a ser este este
freno a la deforestación y si los países
que están complicados y nombremos en la
región bras brasil-argentina por ejemplo
hasta la noticia que me ayuda lleno no
había firmado por ejemplo son países que
tienen claramente
un uso importante de los bosques hay
usos conflictivos agrícola avance de la
frontera agrícola sobre el bosque
entonces hay que hay que tener mucha
rapidez para cumplir esto y el otro la
otra pata digamos de este de estas
situaciones tiene que ver con el hecho
de la reforestación que también es
bastante compleja porque se ha pensado
es cierto que los árboles todos sabemos
fijan el co2 entonces una buena sumidero
de carbono pero lamentablemente esto
también se ha utilizado de manera
indiscriminada entonces estamos teniendo
plantaciones en lugares quizás donde no
debiéramos tenerlas entonces hay que
tener cuidado de que vos qué estamos
hablando ojalá que estemos hablando de
nuestros bosques naturales que son los
mejores sumideros de carbono según las
investigaciones que tienen en carbono en
el suelo de los árboles tienen de todo
una biodiversidad social y servicio
ecosistémicos para la población y no
simplemente en plantaciones de rápido
crecimiento que después van a ser
utilizadas entonces ahí hay un balance
también la letra chica que se habla no
es cierto respecto como ese para la
deforestación yo creo que en todos estos
temas hay mucho de letra chica y eso es
yo creo donde tenemos que toda la
comunidad ya sea científica pero también
ciudadana están muy encima de lo que
está pasando catalina a nivel de
legislación a nivel de políticas
públicas cuáles tienen más peso planes
como por ejemplo este la reforestación
volverá a reforestar esas zonas que han
sido arrasadas para ampliar la frontera
agrícola o los proyectos que van para
reemplazar los carburantes que hemos
usado derivados del petróleo o
energéticos cuáles son los que tienen
más prioridad por lo menos en américa
latina o de los mercados que usted
conoce pues digamos eso depende mucho de
los países y de cuál es su fuente
principal de emisión por ejemplo en el
caso de colombia en su matriz el sector
afo lo que es el uso de la tierra
digamos del sector agrícola ganadero y
otros usos de las tierras es donde más
hay emisión de gases
entonces pues digamos en ese sentido los
planes de deforestación tendrían más
peso que por ejemplo digamos algunos
planes de incluso es muy importante no
nos diciendo que no es importante que
cambiemos nuestra matriz energética y
ataquemos
la energía proveniente de combustibles
fósiles pero en este caso digamos
nuestro nuestra principal fuente son es
el sector a folio
sin embargo y vamos a nivel de políticas
públicas creo que que en latinoamérica
salvo algunas excepciones y digamos un
poco tenemos un caso particular con con
brasil
pero contamos con marcos normativos
avanzados digamos en algunos países en
el caso de chile en el caso de colombia
por ejemplo costa rica que que se
resuelva y es muy progresión exacto es
líder en el marco normativo es robusto
pero es muy importante pasar a la acción
entonces los proyectos y los planes es
donde se canaliza realmente la
implementación donde efectivamente hay
una asignación de recursos unas
capacidades
sinergias y procesos que permiten la
coordinación intersectorial porque esto
no solamente son de las autoridades
ambientales sino sino compete a todos
los sectores y en la medida que los
sectores estén involucrados es donde se
logra el cambio entonces pues yo creería
que a nivel de políticas públicas es
están los proyectos concretos es donde
podemos realmente ver un cambio positivo
pues muchas de estas zonas en donde se
han llevado a cabo diferentes proyectos
como por ejemplo proyectos de
reforestación están en zonas que han
pertenecido a diferentes grupos
indígenas en diferentes países de
américa latina ya vemos los casos que se
han presentado en el norte de brasil en
la amazonía en el chile en la región de
la araucanía y también en el sur de
colombia muchos de estos grupos
indígenas han reclamado la poca atención
que les han dado las autoridades ellos
también han sido protagonistas allí en
la cob 26 han elevado su voz a la más
alta de las autoridades para poder hacer
sentir que también tienen que ser
tenidos en cuenta a la hora de tomar
decisiones para mejorar el medio
ambiente y reversar un poco lo que hemos
hecho veamos
ellos también están presentes en la cob
26 quieren que el mundo sepa que sus
tierras están amenazadas muchos
indígenas son escépticos a las promesas
de los gobiernos de sus países de
proteger sus tierras utilizadas para
actividades extractivistas
recibimos más acaba de hablar el
presidente del ecuador habla de la
protección del cambio climático que el
ecuador está tiene su diversidad muy
grande pero es una mentira porque la
verdad no yo conozco desde la comunidad
de hemos venido desde el territorio y
hemos visto a hoy en día los gobiernos
tienen su plan de sacar el petróleo
otro indígena dice estar preocupado por
la contaminación de las vías fluviales
donde él y su familia viven en chile
en muy poco tiempo en los últimos 100
200 años la gente ha estado explorando
la profundidad de lugares que pensábamos
que aún estaban por descubrir había
personas cuidando esas tierras y ahora
están poniendo minas allí extrayendo el
litio y cosas que nos impiden seguir
viviendo allí en la cumbre climática los
líderes mundiales y jefes de estado se
comprometieron a proteger las
comunidades indígenas y las selvas
tropicales invirtiendo millonarias sumas
dinero con fondos públicos y privados
además para disminuir la deforestación
en esta década países que representan
más del 85% de los bosques del mundo se
comprometieron a detenerla entre ellos
varios de américa latina como brasil
colombia y perú sin embargo los
indígenas no están seguros de que estos
planes se vayan a cumplir y aseguran que
una vez implementada las nuevas promesas
habrá que ver el impacto total
gustavo en la ciudad de panamá y en la
capital de el istmo de panamá qué hacer
con este tipo de situaciones donde se
enfrentan a los territorios ancestrales
de los grupos indígenas que habitaban
históricamente estos países de américa
latina o con los grupos con los
intereses económicos como hacer un
balance sé que es muy difícil no
pretendo que tenga la solución en una
respuesta pero por lo menos abrirnos un
poco el panorama
mira los pueblos indígenas han sido los
que tradicionalmente han protegido
conservado o mantenido los recursos
naturales pues si estamos hablando de
soluciones naturales para mitigar al
cambio climático pero también para
apartarse del cambio climático es
fundamental conservar el rol que tienen
los pueblos y las comunidades indígenas
y bueno hay también un tema de derechos
ancestrales de respeto en la cultura
entonces hay que ser mucho más
cuidadosos cautelosos integrar sus voces
en toda la toma de decisiones que esté
relacionada pues con recursos naturales
con la minería con la extracción de
recursos etcétera etcétera entonces
digamos que no tenemos una historia en
nuestra región pues de buen trato a
estas comunidades hay que cambiar esto
si verdaderamente queremos que la
naturaleza se conserve
doctor pulsar así como hablamos de la
presencia del presidente de eeuu el
primer ministro británico también la
presencia de los diferentes grupos
indígenas también tenemos que hablar de
las ausencias y son la ausencia de rusia
la ausencia de china solamente han
enviado algunos vídeos haciendo anuncios
de algunos compromisos y también la
ausencia de brasil que es uno de los
gobiernos por lo menos el presidente
bolsonaro uno de los más controvertidos
a la hora de hablar de temas
medioambientales
que dicen estás a usted estas ausencias
en esta cumbre qué mensaje nos envía
como lo lee usted
bueno complejo o sea evidentemente son
actores claves sea rusia tiene todos los
bosques siberianos que con un poco de
cambio climático todo esto empezará a
derretirse lo que el permafrost del
bosque es y severiano y por lo tanto
digamos vamos a tener una cantidad de
incendios forestales enorme entonces se
produce un ciclo de retroalimentación
positiva que va generando más y más
incendios en este bosque siberiano china
que hablar del consumo digamos de la
nueva ola de consumo y brasil por
supuesto la amazona yo creo que lo que
hay que hacer es tratar de poner a todos
estos países arriba de la del grupo para
trabajar en la medida que ellos
entiendan que el modelo y su calidad de
vida que un concepto que tenemos que
entender bien su buena calidad de vida
se va a ir definitivamente en un colapso
eso yo creo que es la única manera de
tenerlos arriba es decir aquí nos vamos
a poder seguir viviendo como si el mundo
no tuviera cambio climático
e incluso los escenarios favorables
indican que este 2 grados o 2 grados
como 5 es casi seguro que vamos a tener
eso
y las metas actuales que son ambiciosas
no no logran bajar ese posgrado entonces
hay que hay que ser muy preciso con la
autoridad y con los ciudadanos de esos
países decirles miren no si el día de
mañana no va a ser como fue antes sino
que ustedes no van a tener el agua no
van a tener el aire no van a tener la
alimentación que ustedes usualmente
utilizan entonces yo creo que ahí es
donde hay que hacer clic no no se trata
solamente de un tema monetario sino que
un tema de calidad de vida de los
habitantes de cada uno de nosotros sería
humano de este planeta claro ya estoy
llegando al final del programa
catalina rápidamente quería hablar de la
financiación y el equilibrio a la hora
de financiar los países desarrollados
económicamente tienen muchos recursos y
los países que tienen problemas
económicos pues se ven también en
dificultades para poder acceder a fondos
a nivel internacional para poder llevar
a cabo los planes que tienen que
implementar internamente aquí hay un
desbalance completamente cómo mejorar
esto como garantizar un poco más acceso
a los países menos favorecidos
el acuerdo de parís tiene un principio
que se llama responsabilidades comunes
pero diferenciadas según las capacidades
de cada uno
es decir todos deben aportar en la
consecución de las metas de reducción de
gases pero según las capacidades
entonces en ese sentido digamos en en
copenhague
se define una meta y era movilizar 100
billones de dólares de los países
desarrollados para los países en
desarrollo al 2025 y
alemania y canadá hicieron ahora un plan
el delivery plan para ver cómo se va a
cumplir y las propuestas en 2023 y hay
muchas dudas en este cumplimiento de
este plan
pero digamos que de todos modos hay una
serie de iniciativas y estos compromisos
que se han firmados de movilización de
recursos que ayudan a aliviar un poco el
tema pero efectivamente pues toca que se
pueda cumplir este plan y que realmente
se pueda renovar esta meta de
financiación y que llegue y que se miden
las capacidades necesidades de los
países en desarrollo
cumplir minuto de programa gustado las
conclusiones que nos va a dejar está con
26 30 segundos
y esas conclusiones bueno pues la
conclusión es necesitamos muchísimo más
ambición a parte de todo este aire
caliente declaraciones institucionales
lo que cuenta son los compromisos
nacionales y a día de hoy nos colocan a
2.7 grados tenemos que hacer acelerar 10
veces más duro trabajo doctor puig art
sus conclusiones allí en concepción en
el suelo de chile
bueno que nosotros tenemos que hacer el
cambio que tenemos que tener políticos
que nos representen en estos temas que
la gente cuando vaya a votar piense en
su futuro en el de su hijo y el su nieto
y para eso también hay que tener
político que represente en estos temas
ambientales en catalina por acá en el
estudio para el cierre rápidamente que
nos concentremos en la implementación en
presionar que estos compromisos se hagan
realidad en alzar las voces digamos la
organización en la que yo trabajo como
organización civil tiene que poder
empoderar a las comunidades civiles y
que se alcen las voces para elevar
conciencia pero implementación
implementación pues esas son las
opiniones de nuestros invitados para el
programa de hoy les agradezco por haber
estado con nosotros habernos acompañado
y compartido con nosotros ustedes pueden
seguir dejando sus comentarios y sus
preguntas a través de las redes sociales
sigan con nuestra programación sigan en
france24
[Música]